Hugging,
we are hugging.
I’ve missed the days where my
biggest problem
was an ever present
sing-songy twit.
Drink?
I’m gonna drink,
I am not having this conversation
unless I’m drinking.
I think the most satisfying part of
playing Jaskier in general,
is the multifaceted nature
with which Lauren has
created this character and
Mr Sapkowski.
There is so much more to him I think in this season than the silly jokes,
there’s more than the catchy songs.
We get to see a more
well rounded character,
a textured character
and somebody who is
for the first time in his life
making real moral decisions and
putting his own life at risk.
Thank you.
We… all of us
would be dead without you.
Oh.
It always feels really, really amazing
to approach this character
every time I return to him,
because Lauren just keeps adding
more and more layers
and I’m always so excited to explore
them as the stories progress.
Joe Trapanese, our amazing
composer, and I,
worked really hard on the music
throughout the pandemic before shooting
and it was the first time where I was able
to have a little bit more ownership
over the songs
that Jaskier sings.
♪What for do you yearn?
It’s the point of no return♪
That meant that by the time we
got to shoot the songs,
it really felt very natural
I wasn’t worrying about where
the song was going
on the tonal shifts that
we were aiming to achieve.
♪Watch that butcher burn♪
Turning up on set was exhausting
because we were shooting
all day long
and a lot of these were one takes
which just means that we didn’t cut into it
and that wasn’t as much coverage as usual.
There was no room to mess up.
There was a real performative energy to it,
it felt a bit like performing a play really.
Though it looks like we’re filming indoors
we’re actually exterior.
It looks like we’re in a tavern but
we’re actually outside
so you can actually see the cold
in my breath when I’m singing,
you can actually see all of our
wonderful SA’s, extras,
shivering in the background,
and it meant that we all had to
really come together
and kind of use each other’s
energy throughout the day
to kind of get something that
didn’t look like we were all
freezing our cotton socks off
in the middle of winter.
So we left Jaskier on the top of a mountain
in episode 6 of Season 1.
Somehow he got down.
See you around Geralt.
We get to see him for the first time
standing on his own two feet
discovering his own independence
and discovering who he is when he’s not defined by his friendship with Geralt.
One of the last scenes that I shot
was actually in the jail cell with Henry
and Henry and I got
loads of time to really discuss
and work out where to pitch this.
We didn’t wanna bring in guilt, or shame.
We wanted to bring in
forgiveness and understanding,
which is what all friendships
should be based on.
And it meant that by the time
Henry and I shot that
first scene in the jail cell,
I think I ad-libbed a line, about
shoving something up your…
I can’t remember what it was.
Sir you would not know talent if
I shoved it up your-
Geralt.
And Henry broke in the middle of the first take,
and it just felt really normal,
it felt like we were back
and we were in sync again.
Fuck it.
There was moments where I get to, you know,
dance around the scripts,
but also really enjoy the very natural
chemistry that Henry and I have.
So I think Jaskier knows that the
rift between them isn’t forever,
and sometimes time is required
to heal those kinds of wounds.
You left me on a mountain.
Have you seen these boots?
But also he’s not about to
reignite this friendship easily,
there are new terms to it,
there’s a new dynamic
and he’s perfectly willing to say,
“Hey Geralt we don’t do this anymore,
we do it like this now.”
Don’t fucking Jaskier me,
I’m talking to you,
this is how this works.
We got to see a stronger Jaskier,
a Jaskier that is just as kind,
just as light,
but with a strength in him now.
And with a sense of
self perspective, I guess.
I made new friends, get over it.
Jealous.
To be the mouthpiece for Lauren
in these sort of scenes
is always an absolute joy,
because Sapkowski does
do this in the books,
he does get a little
bit metatheatrical,
he does wink at the reader,
in a very knowing way.
And the best way that we could
translate that into the show
was through Lauren’s writing,
and through Jaskier’s sort of metatheatricality
within the world anyway,
which we’ve already seen.
Here I go again,
just delivering exposition.
Al who was playing the guard on the day,
we were filming about 4
o’clock in the morning,
and we read the scene
together for the first time
and I started ad-libbing,
and our wonderful director Sarah Gorman said,
“Have you guys been practicing this?
Have you guys been rehearsing
in your trailers?”
and we said no we’ve just met for the first time,
but it felt very natural
and there was a real natural chemistry.
♪The long necked warriors
with all their tools…♪
You know it!
Oh yeah, yeah.
So I got to really dance around
with some of the insults…
Am I gonna say it?
Yeah I’m gonna say it.
I drew on pretty much every
single Shakespeare play
that I’ve been in or read.
A qualling, feculent, a beef witted,
hell hated, addlepated gooned…
It meant that we got to
really, really enjoy
Jaskier’s ego for the first time
in the series I think.
You know he’s now famous,
he’s now really well known,
and he’s using that to help people.
But he still got that
recalcitrant side to him,
where if someone says, I didn’t love it…
It’s not your strongest.
We got to go…
Oh yeah…?
Well then explain why, Twitter!
It took me to the fourth verse
to understand they
were different timelines.
Oh did it? Wow.
And that magic kiss?
That was a bit cheap.
Yeah?
And it’s that open sort of
dialogue that I always think,
it’s very like Mr Sapkowski,
but I applaud Lauren for
using this kind of platform
to enjoy the metatheatricality
of the show itself.
Once again, we were shooting exterior,
in spite of the fact it looks interior.
Filming that scene was one of the most difficult,
but rewarding experiences
of shooting Season 2.
I made sure that I stripped myself
of as much artifice,
and indeed clothing as I possibly could
so that I could be
in a very cold space,
with the darkest thoughts that I could
possibly summon up in my head.
When a character like that is
confronted with imminent death,
you’ve got to really find a rawness,
and a natural way of talking.
He tries to bargain,
he tries to fight back,
he goes through all the stages.
I don’t know where they’re going
and I don’t know why you’re doing this to me.
And Chris who plays Rience,
is one of the most incredibly
intense actors,
he’s so still, he brings
the sadism to the character,
the enjoyment of seeing someone else in pain,
which is so wonderful,
because he’s an absolute delight off-set.
He is one of the most wonderful people,
and yet seeing the shift in him
did so much work for me.
I genuinely could
find myself scared,
and fearful of my life.
And this is the first time
Jaskiers not had his best friend
to come in and swoop in
and save him from danger.
And so, for the first time
we see him panicking.
Listen to me please.
Please listen to me,
I... I am a bard.
He doesn’t have a backup plan,
and he can’t talk his way out of it,
and that helplessness,
stayed with me for weeks
after shooting that scene.
I felt very very raw
and emotionally a little
bit vulnerable after it,
because it really required
a lot of emotional energy
to try and commit to it as we did.
The monster mash was grueling,
it was great fun, but it was grueling,
it was very very challenging.
It took us about three and a half weeks,
maybe a month to shoot that entire sequence.
They were long days, lots of stunts.
I spent most of that time under a table,
for about three and a half weeks,
and scrambling around,
and screaming my lungs out,
with lots of men in green tights
jumping around me
as the Basilisk,
so it was a very bizarre experience.
My first impression was actually ad-libbed
in that episode I believe.
I think Freya just walked away
whilst I tried to talk to her,
and then I said something
along the lines of…
Like father, like daughter..
That very much summed up
Jaskier’s outlook towards Ciri.
My outlook towards
Freya is completely different.
I’ve so enjoyed working with Freya,
she’s got such a stillness, and a natural -
a naturalness to her tone when she’s on screen.
I often sneak behind the camera and watch her
takes because I find it so fascinating.
She’s an absolute joy, and so
ridiculously talented
that I can’t wait to see their dynamic
progress into Season 3.
You know there is a sort of kismet,
there is an understanding between them,
and there is something of the weird
Uncle Jaskier about the whole set up.
One big happy family, eh?
No.
I can’t wait to have more scenes with her,
she’s astonishing.